chris is going to start off this hour in
Flint Michigan hey Chris welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show yeah I doing better
than I deserve what's up not too much I
wanted to get your opinion on something
I'm in about sixty five thousand dollars
worth of debt and I just kind of started
your budget yesterday cut every dollar
calm and we have about ninety seven
dollars worth of extra money per month
and honestly I just don't know where to
start
as far as paying off the debt okay
alright well we have a system that we
call the baby steps baby step one is the
first thing I want you to save up a
thousand dollars and then you need to do
that faster than you're talking about I
want you to do that like in a month have
a garage sale let's scratch the some
dollars together if you got any money in
savings
now we don't okay time to get a thousand
bucks then get a little bit of distance
between you and problems not a lot but a
beginner starter emergency fund then the
second step baby step two is to pay off
your debts which is what you're calling
about you list those smallest to largest
a minimum payments on everything but the
little one and attack the little one
with a vengeance when that one's calling
you attack the next one down when that
one's gone you attack the next one down
every time you pay off one you don't
have those payments anymore and you get
to attack the next one down and what
you're going to find is the more passion
that you get about getting out of debt
the more you're going to adjust your
monthly budget and the deeper you're
going to sacrifice the deeper you
sacrifice of course the more money comes
to the program right now we're at ninety
seven dollars and we've got to increase
that right yeah and my wife is also got
a second job and I'm working and getting
a second job as well and that's going to
increase it you know that's good very
good and how much dad have you got not
counting your house about sixty five
thousand and what's your household
income around seventy five thousand okay
yeah we're gonna find more than ninety
seven bucks to go towards
then of the 65,000 how much of that is
cars about 35 ooh
you're awfully deep in cars yes what's
the most expensive car the most
expensive cars around 25,000 yeah you're
probably selling that one okay yeah
you're probably going to get rid of that
one you that's where you bit off more
than you can chew a good rule of thumb
is to not have things with wheels and
motors all added together because things
with wheels and motors all go down in
value okay and if you and you want to go
you want to be buying more things that
go up in value then go down in value so
all the things that have wheels and
motors added together should not be more
than half your annual income and you're
you're over that so yeah you're probably
going to sell the $25,000 car you'll
have to decide that today but that's
probably what's coming in order to get
this thing moving
and that that cuts down the time that
you're get out of debt plan takes and it
gets you back in control again but that
car that car is over the top sounds to
me like you have to work on it you look
at it but that's how you're going to get
started exactly and welcome welcome to
the journey brother you can do it